today on the matt walsh show a new poll
finds that 40 percent yes 40 of gen z
identifies as lgbt what in god's name is
going on there trying to figure that out
today and a witness in the rittenhouse
trial yesterday claims that the d.a
tried to get him to perjure himself plus
jimmy kimmel says that americans only
hate camilla harris because we're all
sexist and a truck driver launches a
long shot campaign for the new jersey
senate wins unseats a powerful incumbent
and now the media would like us to know
that this is all very bad because uh
he's racist big shock in our daily
cancellation we're told that climate
change fears are giving millions of
americans ptsd
is that true we'll discuss that and much
more today on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know as i've been complaining about
with daylight savings time it has uh for
a lot of people it's an extra hour of
sleep for me it just it just deprives me
of sleep even more because the kids wake
up even earlier and all that means is
that for the time that those precious
moments where i actually get to sleep i
need to make the most of it and that's
why i am so happy to have my helix sleep
mattress i don't go anywhere without my
helix sleep mattress uh well it's not
quite true but if i could bring it with
me i would look helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or your back or your stomach or your
sleep really hot or cold with helix
there's a specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique taste you don't need
to take their word for helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress of
2019 and 2020 by gq and wired magazine
just go to helixsleep.com welsh take
their two minute sleeve quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life guaranteed right now helix is
offering up to 200 off and free pillows
with all mattress orders for our
listeners at helixsleep.comwalsh
that's helixsleep.com walls for up to
200 off your mattress order recently a
study conducted by arizona christian
university was published george barna
the university's cultural research
center's director led the research to
call the results of this research
striking would be a significant
understatement it's hard to come up with
one single word to describe this so
we'll just get into it here's the
summary from an article in newsweek it
says 30
of millennials identify as lgbtq
according to a soon to be released study
that's based on scientific polling data
among christians the numbers were lower
but only slightly with just under 30
percent of millennial christians
identifying as lgbtq the portion of the
population that described itself as gay
has varied over the years from 10
percent based on research by alfred
kinsey widely promoted and widely
promoted by the national gay task force
in 1977 to less than six percent
in a recent gallup poll
now a couple of notes about that before
we look at these results more closely uh
you may recall from our discussion of
alfred kinsey a couple months ago that
the 10 figure was completely bogus at
the time
kinsey wanted there to be a large
portion of homosexuals in the country he
wanted to create a society where
heterosexuality was but one mode of
sexuality among an array of equal
options and so he falsified his research
to kind of get the ball rolling so to
speak he surveyed male prostitutes sex
offenders men in prison
carefully choosing from
non-representative samples of the
population and then extrapolated all
kinds of conclusions about male
sexuality based on that
the prevalence of homosexuality was the
least of what he falsely concluded now
this is relevant because it shows how
there's been a very real plot
a plan
yes if you like a conspiracy to
fundamentally change human sexuality
it was set in motion by degenerate
quacks like alfred kinsey and john money
and now we're seeing uh the fruits of
their label labor so a little more from
newsweek it says the poll looked at
so-called millennials defined as someone
born from 1984 to 2002
about 78 million individuals
representing a quarter of u.s population
among millennials 30 identifies lgbtq
lgbtq more than three times that of the
rest of the adult population
and when the researchers broke out uh
the youngest of the group ages 18 to 24
which is really gen z
they found 39
call themselves lgbtq
okay so we're talking
40 nearly 40 percent identifying as lgbt
now if this is true
if these numbers are anywhere close to
accurate
then we are witnessing not even just a
seismic shift in human sexuality but a
full-on transformation unlike anything
the world has ever seen before
many people though on both sides of the
ideological divide for different reasons
don't want to believe or admit that such
a transformation is actually happening
so they have a few ways of trying to
deny or mitigate results like this on
the left
they'll say that this doesn't reflect a
change at all they'll claim that there
have always been this many lgbt people
in society but they just didn't feel
comfortable revealing themselves until
now
that's that's that's what they'll say
but this is not credible because older
generations have also been surveyed
in our current day and age
where everybody is very accepting and
tolerant and all of that older
generations are also surveyed and their
numbers are much much lower
so the left's theory kind of waves a
magic wand over millions of americans
and declares that you know they're all
closeted gays with no evidence at all
for such an assertion
also if we're looking at this from a
purely biological
and evolutionary perspective
it doesn't make any scientific sense
that 40 or 50 or more of a species would
be non-heterosexual
now
the left claims that homosexuality is
biological right
um
then if that's true
then a 40 or 50 percent figure simply
could not happen for evolutionary
reasons
unless you want to argue that evolution
isn't true
keep in mind the left loves to claim
also that homosexual activity exists in
the animal kingdom right you hear this
all the time
well find me a species where nearly half
are homosexual
that doesn't exist it can't exist
because such a species would go extinct
so this theory doesn't work
but you'll have people on the right who
deny it as well they you know simply
because they don't want to believe that
the lgbt brainwashing of kids has really
been this tremendously successful
they just don't want to believe it
it's it's it's something that they can't
wrap their heads around and so they say
no there's no way
and they'll say the numbers here are
wrong yet the problem for them is that
these results are just the latest in a
long line of research
conducted both by right-leaning and
left-leaning organizations and they all
come to the same sort of conclusion
gallup as mentioned uh by newsweek they
did a major poll several months ago they
didn't find that 30 or 40 percent of gen
z identifies lgbt but they did find that
15 identified that way and another 5
percent had no opinion about their own
sexuality
so that's 20
not identifying as heterosexual
a smaller portion but still 10 times
their parents generation and 20 times
their grandparents generation
so whether it's 20 or 30 or 40 it's
almost splitting hairs
the point is that there is a trend here
a very dramatic trend
and it's a trend against spanning
generations which rules out the other
dismissive claim which you still hear
from some on the right that this is all
a fad right
lgbt identification for the kids today
it's like what uh emo or goth was when i
was a kid
but we know it's not just a fed of that
sort because you find this trend against
spanning generations starting with my
grandparents going all the way down to
my kids generation
lgbt identification has risen by large
portions each step of the way until
today
we also know that it's not just a fad
because fads when we were kids were
treated like fads
adults would tell you you know if you
were a goth
an adult would say to you this is a fad
you're gonna look back on this and be
embarrassed
what they didn't say to the goth kid is
this is your truest identity you should
define yourself by your gothness
this is the most important thing about
you here i made you this flag march
through the street with it let everybody
know
this is who you are and will always be
if adults had said that then there would
be there'd still be a lot of people in
my generation today walking around with
dyed hair and makeup
well in fact there are a lot of people
in my generation walking around that way
but not because they identify as goth
and that's the point
so if this is not a fad which it isn't
and if it is not a natural biological
occurrence
which is only today finding its true
expression which it also isn't
then what's going on
well what's going on is social contagion
a kind of mass hysteria a group
hallucination in effect
but one that is constructed
fabricated
okay this is all intentional
it is social engineering on a scale and
at a level previously unknown to mankind
we've seen brainwashing before but never
like this
and never has it started so young
so this seems relevant a video that went
viral uh this week like a million other
videos of this type
uh we've got again
very young boy four years old in this
case
paraded on camera um in the female alter
ego that his mother has imposed on him
and she's very proud of it
let's listen to that
to your face ty
makeup you put makeup on it
how old are you
seven
no how old are you
seven no four
he's seven are you a boy or a girl a
girl a girl
were you born a girl
were you born a girl
when you were a baby were you a girl yes
are you in a boy's body though
yes
yeah
okay tell tick tock bye
bye
[Music]
yeah who who bought him that makeup
this is his choice right who bought him
the uh the little pink dress there
quite an interesting clip once you can
get past the visceral revulsion
you notice the incoherent arbitrary line
the mother draws she'll respect the boys
she'll she will respect the boy's
self-identification his alleged
self-identification as a girl
but not his self-identification is seven
years old and why not
age is more fluid and changing than sex
which doesn't change at all
age is also relative
i mean relative at least to what planet
you're on there are planets in the
universe where that boy would actually
be seven years old
so why can't he identify as seven then
if he wants he says he's seven and the
mother has no problem saying no no no
you're not seven you're mistaken
about how old you are
because you're a little boy and you
don't know you don't understand how age
works
yet well she won't say that to the boy
about his biological sex
and notice how the boy who is uh
supposedly a girl now you can't see this
if you're just listening to the audio
but
they're outside and um and as he's
talking about the fact that he's girl
he's trying to climb on the wall
while while talking about how he's a
girl
now climbing on walls is a boy activity
i have two of them that's what they do
we have the wall smudges to prove it
so this is a boy acting like a boy in
every in every way
it's just that he's been dressed this
way by his mother
and the boy isn't old enough to sort
through this incoherence and sadly he
may never be able to see it for what it
is even when he's older because his
brain is being rewired
his entire conception of himself is
being altered
his mother cannot make him a girl like
she wants but she can change him
drastically and permanently
and a version of this to some degree or
another
is happening to an entire generation
as it happened to much lesser degrees to
generations before them
you know we're worried about our kids
being indoctrinated into critical race
theory
and socialism
and becoming democrats
well sure we should be worried about
that
but none of that when it comes to the
indoctrination of kids none of that
comes anywhere close to this
to generations of kids
being completely
redefined their identities redefined
as we all sit back and watch
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
inflation is making everything more
expensive
the grocery going to grocery stores is
way more expensive than it used to be
and especially if you got to fill up the
gas tank on your way that's that is the
uh that's the insult to injury and so
you got to take advantage of any
opportunity to save money especially
when it's
as easy as this as it is with the get
upside app my listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up just download the get
the free get upside app in the app store
or google play right now and if you use
promo code walsh it gets even better you
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back
don't pay full price of the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
walsh to get up to 50 50 cents a gallon
cashback on your first tank some people
who drive a lot are making two 300 a
month in cash back
and um and then unfortunately all that's
going to be spent um on buying gallons
of milk but still you could use every
penny you could get we all could you can
cash out anytime to your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon and
other brands just download the free get
upside app and use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cash back on
your first tank that's code walsh
all right um sorry you know i had fun
last night my wife for a gift booked me
a ticket to this event at a distillery
here in town where they make uh davidson
reserve
so give a shout out to them
um and you could blank you can uh you
know but you go to the distillery and
you do toward a disability then you can
blend your own your own bourbon
so you'll learn a little bit about how
to identify the different notes and the
flavors and um
and uh and i found out i'm very bad at
that they're trying to sort of teach you
how to how do you pick out like the nose
and then the and then what what comes
after and then the back of your tongue
and where the different here's a there's
a note of oak and a hint of cinnamon and
vanilla and then they give you a you
know
a
kind of a journal to write down your
notes so you figure out how you want to
blend it
and all of my notes there was many many
lines available for for to write notes
but my notes would just say
bad
didn't like
or good me like
so that's about as uh as as
you know as far as i could go but here's
the thing
and i enjoyed it it was a lot of fun
and um the good thing is that this is
the kind of activity that i enjoy
but i would never
book it myself or go to it on my own of
my own volition
so because i'm a man so i need a wife to
kind of like assign it to me
even a fun thing that i want to do i
still need her to make that happen women
don't understand it's about men
there's a lot there's a lot that men
don't understand about women this is one
of the things that at least until you're
married
uh you don't really understand
is that as as men we don't do activities
we're very anti-activity
um we don't involve ourselves in
organized activities
unless we're getting paid to do it
outside of that we just don't do
organized activities
even if it's an activity that we're
interested in doing
and so the woman has to take it upon
herself to kind of figure out what sort
of activities we might actually enjoy
and then coax us along and they're gonna
strike out a lot i mean 99 of the
activities
that your wife gets you into you're
gonna hate but there's like that one
percent there's a lot of trial and error
and at this point my wife has figured
out the one percent which is a great
thing women love activities on the other
hand for women it's different right we
moved to nashville
and within like 95 minutes my wife was
involved in a book club a mom's group
she became like an astronaut i mean all
kinds of activities as soon as we got
there
and then she immediately knew also the
other big thing for me she immediately
knew all of the potential family
activities
for the for for the entire year every
weekend she just knew it i don't know
she got it she walks into a town and
absorbs this information by osmosis or
something and immediately knows and so
then i'll say what are we doing on
saturday and she'll say oh we're taking
the kids to a to an arts and crafts
festival where we'll like paint a
shoebox or whatever
and i'll say can we not though can we
just sit here and do nothing isn't that
a better plan
she says no we got to have family time
and then we go and then i find that i
kind of enjoy painting the shoot box so
this is what you need
uh women for the other thing about my
wife
is she's my activities coordinator she's
also my dedicated troll as you know so
um hearkening back to what we talked
about with the tea fiasco you know we
were at the whiskey tasting she took a
picture of all the whiskeys that were
being blended
and she posted that to twitter with the
caption um adding to my tea collection
which was good well played well played
so here's the latest on the written
house case from the daily wire it says
the judge overseeing the trial of kyle
written house who killed two men in one
or another during a night of riots in
kenosha wisconsin
last year dismissed dismissed a charge
of breaking curfew against the teen on
tuesday
judge bruce schrader tossed an
additional curfew charge on tuesday
ruling that prosecutors had failed to
produce any evidence that a curfew had
been in place
the judge left in place the misdemeanor
gun charges against written house
overruling defense's request to have it
dismissed
and so this is kind of a
a small thing obviously the curfew
violation is the the least of
written houses concerns as far as the
criminal charges go
but you just see how little by little
things are the the the prosecution's
case is chipped away little by little
and then there are also massive chunks
that are chipped away and prosecution
rested yesterday uh so they're done
presenting their case and we can look
back at it now
in its totality and see that there is
simply no case at all but it's a lot
worse than simply having no case
um
what we're seeing now is
is prosecutorial corruption
blatantly
right in front of our eyes
because the real big news from yesterday
was a witness who took the stand
and said this was his claim
that he said under oath
that the prosecution tried to get him to
perjure himself
let's uh let's watch that describe your
meeting with mr binger and mr krauss in
their office objectives
answer it please um
i don't know the date off the top of my
head um but i was called down to
the district attorney's office
i met with mr binger and
i don't remember his name the individual
who's in the blue
um
and we were i was called into a room set
at a table
handed my police statement
got to read over my police statement and
then i was asked if i would like to add
anything
to the police statement and i said i
would not
mr binger pulled out a cell phone and
showed me a video and also a photo
which was actually one photo that i
brought today and asked me to if i knew
who a gentleman was in that photo and i
said i did not
and he asked me to
oh
he said this is
joshua zaminski
um
he mr bingo also has a case with him and
i am subpoenaed for that case also
and
he says well that's who that is he put
the phone down he picked the phone back
up and says who is this
and
i confusingly said like joshua zaminski
and he's like would you like to add that
to your statement and i just felt
i didn't want to change my statement
okay and as a result what did you do
um i hired an attorney and that's mr
rose yes
okay well no big deal there just the d.a
suborning perjury
to try to railroad an innocent man
no big deal nothing to worry about i
suppose
in fact i am i am worried i'm very
worried
that
and this is the cynical pessimistic side
of me coming out that uh which is all
it's finally emerging that i'm a cynic
and pessimist
um
i'm worried that rittenhouse will still
be convicted anyway
even though there's no basis for it
whatsoever
but um
the jury
you know they're not
these people are not uh in
they they they weren't we didn't dig
them out of the ground we didn't pull
them out of a cave they live in society
they know what's going on
uh they're
they're local so they saw for themselves
many of them what happened in kenosha
and so they are also you would you would
really hope that they would do the right
thing
and there could be no excuse here for
doing the wrong thing and sending an
innocent man to prison
but
you know they know that if they
acquit this guy they're probably going
to be doxxed not not probably they will
be
because the left is is not going to
tolerate that
they'll be doxxed and uh and there's a
chance that their lives could be
destroyed or worse
so that's what ridden house has
against him and that's that's pretty
significant
so i'm very worried that that he'll get
convicted anyway and i'm worried about
it
number one because an innocent man is
now in jail and so i feel very bad for
kyle rittenhouse
but also on a much on a much
broader level in a larger scale
this would just be the death of legal
justice in america
really not to put
too fine a point on it this this would
be the death of legal justice
now you might argue that that that
happened a long time ago or it never
existed but
whatever the case after something like
that
we cannot claim that we have a justice
system
because you know it's it's one thing and
this is something that i've heard from
people trying to minimize
the perjury or the subordinating of
perjury by the d.a
there have been plenty of people on
social media saying well da's do this
all the time you know you're living in
your shelter a little bubble if you
don't think this sort of thing happens a
lot
maybe it does it wouldn't shock me to
find out that it does
there are also innocent men who go to
prison that also happens
but for it to happen out in the open
with everybody watching
that's an entirely different sort of
situation
you know for prosecutors to pull all
kinds of dirty tricks
uh in dark and smoky rooms you know
hatching plots and doing what they can
to railroad innocent people again
i know that that has happened before
but if we're at a point where they can
do it in front of everybody
on national television on during a case
that's being watched by the entire
country everything is being is uh on
video
and they still do it
well then that's that's just it there's
no
because in the past if you had corrupt
da's which again you're always going to
have that
but they would have to kind of work
around the law and they would have to do
do these kinds of things in the dark
which means that there is still
something that they're there's something
there that they're that they have to
navigate around
there is the law there's justice and
they're trying to navigate around it and
manipulate it
but if they can do it out in the open
what that means is there's no justice
and there's nothing for them to even
manipulate or work around
so yeah there is there is actually a big
difference
between an innocent man being railroaded
and sent to jail
um
and it it happening in a way where
you know it's people don't notice and
they hide it
there's a difference between that
and the state basically announcing hey
we're railroading this guy sending him
to jail do something about it i bet you
won't
those are two very different things both
are bad
but one is the death of uh of
of the legal system it's the death of
the legal system and so that's that that
is really what's at stake here i believe
okay jimmy kimmel uh he has a theory as
to why people don't like camila harris
it's because america is sexist and
racist i mean that's the only reason why
it's the only reason anyone could
possibly not like camilla harris a phony
shill of a woman who launched her
political career by performing sexual
favors for a married man then flunked
out of the presidential race got the job
as vp for affirmative action reasons i
mean why would anyone dislike this woman
except because of sexism racism that's
what jimmy kimmel thinks anyway let's
listen to that
if anything can get the american people
fired up it's infrastructure so
and biden is alone americans really
aren't happy with this vice president
kamala harris kamala harris has an
approval rating of 28 which is
makes no sense because she basically has
nothing to do i mean it's like
criticizing a backup quarterback tom
brady's okay
i don't love the way blaine gabbard has
his legs folded on the bench i have to
be honest
commonly approval rating
of 28 is even lower than the 30 percent
who approved of dick cheney in 2008
after he shot a guy in the face
i think these people are forgetting that
at least 10 of the those polled approved
of dick cheney because he shot a guy in
the face
i think i know why kamala's ratings are
low besides sexism and racism which are
the obvious ones
it's because whenever she's next to joe
standing near him behind him she looks
like an assassin she looks like
nebula next to thanos ready to right
especially with the mask
hey kamala this guy's being a wise guy
show them what we do to wise guys
my god but i painfully unfunny
really is painful
but
and and by the way the the hilarious
jokes about shooting uh someone in the
face does has he
is the elephant in the room here alec
baldwin where has he made some hilarious
alec baldwin jokes maybe he has i tend
to doubt it
um but you know why he does this kimmel
has gone full woke strategically
and that that's of course is obvious
that's why they're all doing it but he
has a very personal reason this is the
tribute that he is paying to the mob so
that they don't cancel him
for his whole decades-long history of
politically incorrect comedy
because prior to his rebirth as this
woke politically correct
boring figure
prior to that his whole deal was to be
politically incorrect i mean the guy
wore blackface
everybody knows that he did
it he somehow has escaped scrutiny for
that
um he had the man show that every single
episode ended with
uh large breasted scantily clad women
jumping on trampolines
and that was really the least of it in
terms of the uh
on pc
material on that show
so he knows that the only way he's got
to stay one step ahead of it
um because he's you know you might say
well he's a democrat and they know it so
they're not gonna cancel him for that
reason no matter what but that that's
not enough
considering the fact that he's a white
man
now if he was non-white or if he was uh
non-heterosexual that's one thing he
could do
maybe jimmy kimmel should just come out
as gay or transgender or something and
then he could start being funny again
if he ever was funny which is arguable
and he'll then he'll have some cover but
for now as a heterosexual white male
uh even just being democrat being kind
of vaguely left-wing isn't good enough
so every single day on his show he has
to bring his offerings before
the woke gods
with this kind of stuff
so they'll let they'll let him uh
continue at least for one more day being
uncanceled that's basically what's going
on there
all right i got to play this for you um
and it relates back to what we started
the show with
how do we end up in a situation where um
you know millions of kids a huge
percentage of kids identifies lgbt well
we know that this is social engineering
that goes on
uh it happens in a lot of homes and it
certainly happens in the public school
system
and uh especially in public school
systems in virginia loudoun county is
not the only insane school district of
virginia uh fairfax is just as bad if
not worse so here's the latest out of
fairfax let's watch this
some virginia students as young as 12
years old will be asked about their sex
life dating life home life and more 12.
these are the kinds of topics that will
be on the 2021 fairfax county youth
survey which is a collaboration between
fairfax county government and fairfax
county public schools seven news
reporter nick monok has the details all
new at five
eighth 10th and 12th grade students in
fairfax county will have the option of
participating in the 2021 fairfax county
youth survey the survey begins with
asking students how old they are whether
they are male female or transgender and
the survey asks students their sexual
orientation their race and their
experience at school the survey also
asks students several questions on how
they spend their time after school
questions on their home life bullying
their feelings during the past 12 months
plus how often students use tobacco
alcohol and other drugs it doesn't stop
there the fairfax county youth survey
asked students questions about their
sexual behavior including questions like
have you ever had sexual intercourse how
old were you when you had sexual
intercourse for the first time how many
people have you had sexual intercourse
with
and during the past three months how
many people have you had sexual
intercourse with there are more explicit
questions on the survey we posted it on
wjla.com and we should mention this
isn't the first time uh yeah so there
you go i mean
keep in mind this this is not anything
new
which certainly does not excuse it i
just want you to know how widespread
this is i can remember when i was in
public school
getting surveys
very similar to that
now there weren't any questions about
being transgender back then because that
didn't basically didn't exist
but um
or was all but non-existent but
in terms of asking about your
sexual activity and that sort of thing
drug use
all of that what's what's going on at
home you know um i can remember surveys
like that when i went to public school
at from from a young age
so the public school system has been
doing this and the question is
um
several questions one of them being how
is this any of your business
uh it is none of your business
why why do you need to know
why does anyone in the public school
system and i don't care if the surveys
are anonymous and kids can choose to
take it
first of all any any anything anytime
we're told that oh kids have a choice
in the context of public school
you always have to take that with a
grain of salt
there are a lot of things that are
allegedly a choice in public school that
really that really aren't
uh because this the school system has a
way of you know they have a captive
audience
and the kids are there in that
government building for those many hours
a day for so much of their of their
lives through their formative years and
so
the schools have a way of
compelling and convincing kids to make
choices that maybe they wouldn't
otherwise make but whether it's a choice
or not whether it's
anonymous or not
there is no reason why you need to know
this information there's no reason why
this is any of your business
as i always say this there is no
moral difference really between
something like this a survey given to 13
year olds at school
asking them about their
sexual history
no difference between that and an adult
a strange man going up to a kid on the
playground and saying hey
have you ever had sex tell me about your
sexual history no difference
for for a long time we have kind of
carved out
and this seems to be changing now as
parents have
woken up a little bit to the realities
of what's going on in the school system
but but for a long time we had carved
out this massive exception for the
school system
and and sort of implicitly or explicitly
agreed that they should have access to
information that no other adult we would
ever let any other adult access
they should know you know through
surveys like this also keep in mind that
the school system
is going to know things about the kids
in its care that their parents don't
even know and that's the whole idea
this is a way as cults
always do this is this is kind of like
brainwashing 101 in fact i would bet
i've never been to uh as a scientology
center but
i would bet that if you went to
scientology you wanted you know if you
went if you were curious about
scientology or you went into any other
cult
very early on in the indoctrination
brainwashing procedure you'd be filling
out a survey
very similar to that
because they want to know all this stuff
about you
but the other thing that cults do is
they want to sever your attachment
to anyone else in your life
now cult brainwashing is all about
isolation
don't worry about your parents
if we're talking about adults don't
worry about your kids and your spouse
okay that's not who you should be
worried about we want you to be attached
to to this to the to the group
uh to the cult
and that's what's that's how school
systems have operated
that is largely how we have ended up
with 40 lgbt
identification among among kids
because of the cult-like approach of
public school
and this is this this is the project
early on i mean as soon as you drop your
kid off for preschool or kindergarten
they're going to set to work to sever
your child's attachment
from you
kind of kind of cut that cord
and then re not because they want
independent
kids they want kids to be independent
thinkers no they're going to refasten
that attachment to themselves
um
but as i said i think people are finally
maybe maybe finally waking up to this
which is which is one good development
here's one other thing there's a new
marvel movie out apparently nobody likes
it but it's directed by a woman which
means you aren't allowed to not like it
here's a critic from i think he's from
variety explaining why if you don't like
this this movie it's just because you're
you're a sexist
turtles from director and co-writer
chloe zhao has opened in theaters
critics have weighed in on it and it has
been very divisive actually drawing the
lowest rated rotten tomato score of any
mcu film
in history thus far
first of all elizabeth it is not a bad
movie in the slightest i think it's one
of marvel's best efforts thus far has
great action it focuses a lot on story
it's diverse has great characters all
that i think this speaks to a larger
problem that is in the industry anytime
a woman takes on the action genre which
has been typically made for men to helm
people come harder on that filmmaker
when she takes it on i think it's i
think it's the issue that needs to be
addressed because it does not draw that
criticism that it's been receiving i
agree with you a hundred percent right
when you started talking about this i
said
imagine that the film that is directed
by a woman has the lowest score on
rotten tomatoes not warranted
they really they only know one tune
that's all they know you gotta
you gotta feel uh sorry for them a
little bit they're they're humming the
only tune they know
um
yeah
of course the exact opposite is actually
true
the exact opposite you
women
directors are given much more i mean
critics bend over backwards to find
reasons to like films directed by women
that's that's the reality now i haven't
seen eternals but um
something tells me if it's getting a if
it if a superhero movie
helmed by a woman and starring a diverse
cast is getting bad reviews on rotten
tomatoes it must be the worst movie ever
made because they will look for any re
they will cling on to anything
that they can find
they'll look for any handle to cling on
to anything
so that they could justify giving it a
positive review and if they can't i mean
i almost want to see this movie now
just because it's that bad
this is a woke mar critics love marvel
movies
um
and they they love woke movies they love
movies that are that are directed by
women
the guy there says a diverse cast they
love all of that
what could possibly have gone wrong in
that movie that would make them give it
a bad review that's amazing i'm amazed
by that
you have to try hard i mean you as a
woman director you have to try very very
hard
to earn bad reviews
gotta respect it in some ways
um
why don't people like it well probably
because it's a bad but but also consider
this this as well that uh maybe people
are
in terms of the audience anyway maybe
not critics but
the audience might be tired of superhero
movies a little bit by now
like 20 years
straight of 50 superhero movies a year
it's like at a certain point maybe
people get tired of it that's my theory
okay um one other thing i wanted to
mention i almost forgot
um as i teased in the opening
edward durr was the truck driver in new
jersey who ran this is a long long shot
campaign for the state senate
um as you've probably heard he spent
like 150 bucks on his campaign he
basically spent no money on it had no
advertising um this is a he's a truck
driver it's a normal guy and he decided
that he was tired of what was going on
with his local politics and so he did
the most american thing imaginable and
he said i'm going to run for office
myself
and try to make a change i'm not just
going to i'm not going to just vote or
i'm going to do more than that i'm going
to try to get into office myself and he
won and it's amazing and he unseated a
powerful incumbent which is an
incredible story
but
he's a but he's a republican
truck driver
uh which means the media of course hates
him and so they're looking for a reason
this is this is the washington post they
say edward durr was such a long-shot
candidate in his new jersey state senate
race that no one seemed to notice
something rather striking about him he
had a history of posting bigoted
misogynistic derogatory comments on
social media
um and the headline says in fact that
they said that the social media posts
were racist
his racist social media posts
but then it goes on to expl to tell us
what what are the racist social media
posts so that's in the next paragraph
here and um i don't know you you stop me
when you hear racism
muhammad was a pedophile he wrote in a
2019 tweet that also described islam as
a false religion and a cult of hate and
other online posts since last year he
has called the chronovirus the china
virus
blamed an influx of illegal aliens for
spreading disease
used the moda motto of the far-right q
anon conspiracy movement
and compared vaccination mandates to the
holocaust
he also denigrated vice president harris
on facebook writing that she had earned
her position only as a result of her
race and gender well how dare he say
that
i i can't imagine anyone will make that
accusation against camille harris except
when i did just like five minutes ago
so um that's it that's as far as i could
tell i scanned i skimmed through a
little bit more here
um
and as far as i can tell
that's that's that's that's it those are
the racist big where's the racism
exactly
now let me ask you something washington
post paul fair he's who wrote this paul
you do know that
islam is not a race right
that's a religion
and so
edward durr i don't know what his
religion is assuming that he's well he's
he's not muslim so we know that
and so if you're not a member of a
religion then that means that you think
it's a false religion if you didn't
think it was a false religion then you'd
be part of that religion wouldn't you
so every single person who is not muslim
on earth thinks that islam is a false
religion otherwise they would be muslim
they might not all say it but they think
it
just like every non-christian person
thinks that christianity is a false
religion it is a religion that is false
but even that aside how is that
racist
muhammad was a pedophile
well it is a historical fact that
muhammad was involved with what a
nine-year-old girl so
are you su suggesting that are you
defending that
washington post
but even if he even if that's not true
it's muhammad is not a race he's a
historical figure
other than that
influx of illegal aliens are helping to
spread disease well that's obviously
true
china virus
he says a motto of a motto of the q anon
conspiracy movement but they don't
notice they don't tell you what the
motto is that he used
because it was probably something like
what are they recently we've been told
that motto is like protect our children
things like that those are those are
mottos of the q anon conspiracy movement
so this is uh just a totally false hit
piece trying to
penalize this guy for
getting involved in local politics and
committed what's the real city committee
well the real city committed is it is
that he beat a democrat how dare he he
must be racist and so that's what we
learned
all right now time for the comment
section
[Music]
mike says matt's love of speaking about
home financing is astonishing well thank
you for noticing that it is one of my
great passions as you know and i'm just
glad i'm glad you picked up on that and
um
you know it's good to know when my
passions
come through because that's what this
show is all about
uh let's see another comment says matt
you were a beekeeper so mocking george
hudson for being an entomologist is
dangerously ironic yeah i i was a first
no i'm not not i was a beekeeper i'm
still a beekeeper once a beekeeper
always a beekeeper even though i don't
currently
keep bees
i still identify as a beekeeper so
please respect that
but i also have not tried to change
um time itself to accommodate me
okay when i am beekeeping
if i want to go out and do some
beekeeping and it's dark out
then i feel disappointed and i say well
i can't be keep right now because it's
dark out
i don't go lobby
the u.n or something to can we change
the clocks and try to maybe go to nasa
is there some way you can slow down
the rotation of the earth
i don't do that because i'm not a
megalomaniac
like george hudson
one of the great villains of history
um ronan says matt you keep saying that
the number one way to help the daily
wires legal case is to become a member
for those of us who already have a
membership or want to do more is there
anything else we can do
um yeah you can donate your internal
organs uh we keep them in a vat in the
break room so
just send those in
don't ask any more questions
uh let's see
christopher says two years ago matt came
out against daylight savings calling it
stupid last year he called it an amazing
magical thing that we do this year he
switched back to calling it stupid i
can't wait for next year for matt to
call it the force which keeps our
society intact when he wakes up late for
church but is saved by the extra hour
uh
i i don't
i shouldn't have to tell you christopher
this is my truth
you know this is my lived experience my
experience changes
much like the time changes
and do i have to tell you now what's
going to happen to you
for mocking me in who while i am living
in my truth and speaking my truth you're
obviously banned from the show
um
let's see what else do we got uh
personal account says matt you're
misinterpreting the dog it's not that he
dislikes you don't be nicer to him he
recognizes you as the alpha of your
family that's why he barks at you he's
challenging the leader
dominate over him without being abusive
puff out your chest walk with a straight
back and with certainty walk into the
room without looking at him walk through
him instead of around him walk through
like what kick him out of the way what
do you think walk through him
get a bit fiery back at him when he
barks at you speak using your core
reinforce that you are the alpha of the
whole family
jess says man it's not that you haven't
earned your place in the pack it's that
you haven't asserted yourself as alpha
which really should have been done as
soon as the dog was adopted there's
still hope though and if you want the
barking at you to stop you're gonna need
to figure out how to assert your
dominance as alpha so there's a lot of
comments like this people are chiming in
on my uh the dog quandary which i
appreciate what i'm getting and this is
the the theme like all the comments what
i'm getting from this is that i need to
i need to be meaner to the dog is what
you're telling me that's what you're
telling me
and i can do that i mean in general any
time someone tells me that i can solve
the problem by being an even meaner
son
you know that's i can do that that i can
do
though it is annoying to hear this that
this animal thinks he's the alpha in my
home
where does he come off and you know but
then he also runs away like he'll bark
and then he runs away so
you coward show yourself you're coward
he thinks that i'm some sort of threat
but then he doesn't
he's all bark and no bite which i guess
is good
i guess i would really prefer that well
as most of you know the daily wire filed
a lawsuit against the federal government
in order to find to fight these
tyrannical vaccine mandates and the
great news is that within a week of
following the lawsuit the daily wire has
already seen a huge boost to the case
we've already had a one victory on the
way hopefully to the ultimate victory
the fifth circuit court of appeals
issued a temporary stay over the weekend
preventing biden's mandate from actually
going into effect citing grave statutory
and constitutional issues
which is excellent news but it doesn't
mean the fight is over the fight really
is just beginning it's not just the
daily wires employees that we're
fighting for here it's the medical
freedom for all americans if you believe
in your medical freedom and you want to
support the fight against tyranny take a
minute to sign our petition against
biden's authoritarian mandate the daily
wire has a goal of collecting one
million signatures which would send a
powerful message to biden and the legacy
media
that the american people will not comply
hundreds of thousands of americans have
already signed the petition in just a
few days and we believe that we can get
500 000 by midnight tonight but we need
many more people to stand up with us to
reach that goal so please head to
dailywire.com do not comply to sign the
petition today and help us get to 500
000 signatures by midnight tonight and
also
our senile leader was elected to one of
the most powerful positions in the world
a year ago now and it's just time that
we sit back and unpack his
administration's failures and how it's
affecting the american people tune in
tonight to catch an all-new episode of
backstage where we discuss the turning
of the tide and we will all talk about
whether or not
we like joe biden and i'm going to be
interested to find out what the other
guys have to say on that subject join me
bench pair of jeremy bourne michael
knows andrew clavin tonight at 7 00 pm
eastern 6 pm central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel
dailywire but wait there's more even
though we've uh we're locked in the
middle of a battle with federal
government daily wire won't let that
stop us from growing our platform we're
launching daily wire now which means
you'll be able to stream all of your
favorite daily wire shows on vizio
smartcast tune in to watch candice
discuss current events or watch any of
the other hosts there's always something
interesting to stream watch daily wire
now exclusively on vizio watch free plus
streaming app on channel 162 to access
the content you love 24 hours a day
seven days a week only on vizio
smartcast now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we're canceling yale university
there are of course many reasons to
cancel yale many reasons to cancel all
all ivy league universities along with
the whole university system starting
with the fact that the whole thing is a
giant scam a ponzi scheme
building millions of young people out of
billions of dollars
collectively and giving them nothing of
value in return for it but that is all
mostly beside the point for today
yale is cancelled for this study as
reported by the independent it says a
survey has revealed that more americans
than ever are fearful of the ravages of
man-made climate change causing many to
suffer anxiety or depression yale
university's climate change in the
american mines survey found that an
all-time record 70 percent of americans
are now very or somewhat worried about
global warming
researchers added the percentage of
those very worried increased 10 points
since march
americans perception that global warming
is a threat has increased dramatically
and for times for the first time a
majority of americans now say that the
people
in the united states are being harmed
right now by global warming
noah oderberg a psychologist working in
oakland
that's an unfortunate last name oderberg
hopefully he didn't have any you know bo
problems in school because that just
would have been way too cruel he told
abc7 you may have you may have heard of
ptsd post-traumatic stress disorder a
psychiatrist came up with pre-ptsd
because it's not a trauma that's already
occurred it's a fear of a future trauma
so it's the new idea and it involves
anxiety and depression it's very new in
the field of psychology is not prepared
for it
eco-anxiety is a growing problem among
young people
and so on and so on okay
now first of all
i suppose i really should be cancelling
the psychiatry field for this
but i think i've already done that
multiple times
and it's for reasons like this pre-ptsd
so
pre-post traumatic stress
as a matter of basic linguistic logic
why wouldn't you just call it
pre-tsd
that sounds better too or better yet
call it nothing
we don't need a new term a new acronym
for the fear of things that haven't
happened yet
that's not
pre-ptsd that's just called anxiety
that's precisely what anxiety is by
definition stress and fear and worry
about the unknown
that what that which might happen
that's anxiety it's the fear of
possibility
children feel anxiety
in the dark because of what monsters
they imagine might be lurking in it turn
the lights on the anxiety goes away
the unknown turns into the known so this
is basic psychology we don't need a new
turned term to describe it
also
most people complaining about ptsd in
general
don't really have ptsd
most people on earth
certainly in the west
have never been traumatized by anything
they only imagine they've been
traumatized because they're neurotic and
they're self-absorbed and they're weak
trauma is real people do suffer from it
but it's not nearly as common as the
psychiatry industry leads us to believe
and pre-trauma trauma from something
that hasn't even happened yet is
definitely not real it can't be real
you can't be traumatized by something if
it hasn't happened
you're not traumatized by your fears of
the future you're uncomfortable you're
sad you're anxious
these are all human emotions
every human deals with them
get over yourself and live your life but
of course here i am engaging with the
results of this survey as if the results
are real when they aren't
how do i know it isn't real
do i have a
study or a survey of my own to debunk it
no i just have common sense which is
often a better judge and based on my
common sense and my experience as a
human being in this world i know that i
have never in my life even one time even
once
met someone in real life and had a
conversation with them where they
divulged that their top concern in life
is climate change i've never met anyone
who would say that
i've talked to a lot of people as we all
have about their worries and fears that
has never been at the top of anybody's
list that i've talked to
or even on the list
and yet 70 feel this way 70
now you could call this anecdotal that's
fine here's something that's not
anecdotal this is simply a fact about
society
almost nobody
to include the climate change activist
is actually acting like they're worried
about climate change at all
the claim that most people are deeply
worried about man caused climate change
is a theory that predicts certain things
about the world right
so if you didn't know anything about
society
and someone told you that climate change
is a big problem and uh the world's
gonna come to an end because we're
driving cars and stuff
and uh everyone's really worried about
it you know
and and you didn't know anything you'd
been you've been living in a cave all
this time and you didn't know anything
about society
and you were told that and you believed
it
you would go out into society expecting
to see that reality reflected in the way
people live their lives and go about
their their daily lives and it's just
not at all
because when i look around i don't see
those predictions verified nobody with
only the rarest exception
is living in a way that you would expect
people to live if they really believed
that humanity was on the brink of
extinction because of modern technology
and fossil fuels and all the rest
so environmentalism is one giant pageant
it's a charade
none of these people are making any
significant changes to their lives
they're not
now there is one caveat here i'm
claiming that almost none of the adults
pretending to care about climate change
actually do and i stand by that almost
all of their eco fears and anxieties are
made up they're invented it's a lie
but that only applies to the adults
i am certainly willing to believe that
the psychological terror campaign being
waged against kids on this subject is
indeed sincerely effective
anxiety comes from the unknown and for
children almost everything is an unknown
they are ignorant they're innocent
they're confused
they're also helpless
and that's why adults adults who are not
scumbags anyway shield their kids from
even valid worries and concerns because
there's nothing the kids can do with the
information so if i thought that i was
going to lose my job
and uh and lose my house we'd all be
homeless i'd make a lot of people very
happy it would make me happy
and that would be a very real thing to
to worth worrying about right
um and a very real
risk but i wouldn't tell my kids
i would shoulder that psychological
burden myself alone because there's
nothing the kids can do with it or about
it
i wouldn't sit my kids down and say you
know daddy's really worried i mean
there's a chance it might not happen but
i might lose my job we might be homeless
you're going to lose everything that you
uh all of your possessions will be we'll
be gone like i would not i wouldn't sit
to sit them down and say that to them
because it's not a weight that they
should be made to carry because they
can't carry it anywhere or do anything
with it
all they can do with it is suffer
helplessly
so that's why we shelter them
why we should shelter them
let them be free and joyful and innocent
for as long as they can
so all of this is a long way of saying
that even if the world was going to come
to an end in 10 years because there are
too many soccer moms driving minivans i
still wouldn't tell my kids
i still wouldn't tell them
why would i all they could do with that
information is be afraid they'd live
their last 10 years in fear and for what
so even if it was true that the
apocalypse was upon us
you would still be an abusive selfish
piece of crap for telling your kids
about it
but now consider the fact that it's not
true
and no adult really truly deep in their
heart believes that it's true and yet
many of them still voice this nonsense
on their kids
you've got a bunch of maladjusted
unstable miserable fearful adults who
have decided that their kids shouldn't
be allowed to have joy and innocence in
their lives either
you know they say their kids basically
if i can't figure out how to be happy in
this world then neither should you
they tell the kids horror stories about
climate change and scare them about the
coronavirus
and spin wild yarns about systemic
racism and nazis and white supremacists
roaming the streets and purposefully
drain all of the hope and joy out of
these kids lives
turning them into shaky nervous high
strung wrecks like themselves that's
what makes this all so damn sinister
and it's why we should say that not only
yale but all environmentalists
especially those needlessly scaring kids
are today canceled
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire
on today's episode a new federal
indictment further undermines the steele
dossier the u.n climate summit raises
serious human rights questions and elon
musk makes more headlines
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire